I'm Danny Meyer and I'm the CEO of the
Union Square hospitality group in New
York City.
I think the key has been to start every
restaurant with a sharp point of view,
so we go into each restaurant knowing
what it is we're trying to say.
It's like writing a story but,
but then here's where it's different
from a story.
It's a highly interactive experience and
so the people who come to the restaurant
may like part of your original point of
view,
but they may want you to do things a
little bit differently and so then it
really becomes an ongoing dialogue where
you're listening to how the people who
like your restaurant would like it even
more if only you shifted a little bit
and so you're having a dialogue with
your guests.
You're having a dialogue with your
staff.
I think it's really important to keep
the staff is engaged as possible because
at the end of the day,
the restaurant itself as an inanimate
object and it's the human beings who
work there that are the reason that
people like you either want to come back
or not and there's a fine line,
you know,
I'm knocking on wood right now,
but in 24 years I've never had the
experience of closing the restaurant and
the,
the real fine line is that you've,
you've got to give people enough of the
things they returned for,
but you've got to give people enough new
things so they'll come back as well and
if you take away all the reasons that
they came,
they came back,
they may not want to return,
but if you don't change things they may
not want to return.
So there's the art.
What any of the new media is,
is actually very old,
which is that,
that it's human nature to want to
recommend things to people you like and
to want to denigrate things to people
you liked that you didn't like.
I think that's,
that's always been human nature.
We used to call it word of mouth,
now it's word of the elk or word of
twitter or whatever,
and so it's really not a new thing,
but I think that that anyone who has any
kind of a business who's not paying
attention to what the world or what
their customers are saying is,
is making a mistake.
Now,
it's equally important that if you're a
radio,
you want to have antenna that are sharp
enough to pick up the stuff that's out
there,
but if,
if your antenna are so sensitive that
they pick up everything,
you're going to pick up static as well
that may not be particularly useful.
So such a critical thing to learn to
tune in the constructive stuff and tune
out the stuff that's just hurtful.
The restaurant will be 11 years old this
year.
And,
uh,
I think the secret of any restaurant is
you've just got to stick at it.
You've got to stick to the things that
you believe in and you've got to listen
really carefully.
In the case of 11 Madison Park,
we listened very,
very carefully and we realized that our
early point of view wasn't necessarily
on the money rather than people using it
when we first opened it as a Brasserie,
which is pretty much what I had
envisioned it as they said in instead of
saying this is the best brasserie food
I've ever had in my life,
which it would have been if they wanted
to use it as a brasserie.
They said this food doesn't seem to be
stacking up against this gorgeous decor,
and so in order to make 11 Madison Park
into a restaurant that could fulfill its
greatest potential,
we had to not only listen to our guests,
but we had to listen to the architecture
because the architecture,
the bones of that building are not going
to change.
It's a gorgeous,
beautiful space with no light streaming
in.
And so I feel like we finally gave the
space,
the restaurant it deserved.
I moved to New York because I couldn't
get out of my system.
I'm a midwesterner and I,
I really thought that I'd end up maybe
in Chicago.
I felt like St Louis might not be quite
big enough for me,
but I'd gone to school in Connecticut at
Trinity College and I spent a lot of my
weekends down in the city just eating
the city.
Literally.
I went to the horse races.
I would go to Broadway shows that go to
watch jazz restaurants obviously,
and I just like looking at people.
I liked the jolt of energy that,
that I got when I drove off the FDR
drive into the city for the first time,
which I presume is still there,
but now that it's part of me,
I don't feel it quite to the same
degree,
but I could literally feel a jolt and I
just,
you know,
I'm curious.
I like to look at how any block on the
street can change.
Literally from day to day.
Storefront can change.
You can look up and see,
you know,
windows up above that have changed the
kind of human beings that are seemingly
from every corner of the earth who have
something to say and something to
express are here.
And that's what I wanted.
When I first came to New York,
I didn't think I would probably be here
for more than a year,
but a one year has now turned into a
quarter of a century and I'm still here.
I grew up in St Louis,
Missouri and I basically have,
you know,
two incredibly fond memories of being a
teenager there.
As soon as I could get the keys to my
parent's car.
One was going to Ted drewes frozen
custard and one was going to stay,
can shake where back in those days they
had a curbside service.
So,
you know,
you would have after a party you go to
steak and shake or after going to you're
a rock concert and go to steak and
shake.
And it was uh,
it,
it dawned on me when we had an
opportunity to create a reason for
people to use this beautiful park,
Madison Square Park,
morning,
noon and night.
And that makes a park safer when people
are using it.
That in New York where we don't have a,
an automobile culture necessarily,
we still have reasons that human beings
want to get together.
And,
and so whereas these burger and shake
stands,
you know,
from the 19 fifties,
19 sixties,
even the 19 seventies really grew up in
areas where people use their cars and
they would hang out in the parking lot.
We said,
well,
why can't a parking lot be a park?
And that's how it came to be and tell
you what we envisioned or we dreamed of
what it could be,
but never imagined that people would
fall in love to the degree that they
have
shack burger.
But I'll,
I'll eat almost anything on the menu.
It's not really a very long menu.
I mean,
I'm very happy getting a Chicago dog.
I love the bird dog,
which is the,
uh,
chicken bratwurst.
I'm in total love with the shroom burger
and a,
my favorite custard of all which,
which I just asked people to make for
me.
And sometimes it's on the menu is the,
uh,
just getting vanilla custard with coffee
in it.
There's no one that I look to now for
any one thing,
but there are definitely people,
sadly,
many of them are no longer living that I
think about when I get to a crossroads.
I think about my dad who entirely gave
me my love for food and wine and no
giving,
showing people a good time.
He had been in the travel business and
even had a couple of restaurants before
he died.
I think of my maternal grandfather who
really helped to show me that it's
reasonable enough to invest in your
community because it's the right thing
to do,
but also that it's good business to do
that.
And um,
from a professional restaurant
standpoint,
I think of another person who passed
away a few years ago from Paris named
John Claude free,
not who ran a fantastic restaurant
called Thai avant.
And he really showed me that,
that having a really,
really refined restaurant did not need
to be exclusive from having a good sense
of humor that you could have fun taking
service seriously.
Oh boy.
I'd probably think about my 21st
birthday at a Trattoria in Rome.
And it was a simple meal,
but it was great.
The auntie pasta was perfect.
The Spaghetti Alla Carbonara was right
on the money liters and liters of cheap
red wine.
That was just fine.
Vitiello Allah Bolin was just perfect
for me.
A great meal has as much to do with the
people I'm with
and the comfort that I feel in the
setting.
The food has to be absolutely delicious.
But I think that sometimes people put
too much emphasis on always having to
find the best.
If I hadn't answered that particular
meal in Rome,
the other place I was thinking about
would be just getting a great pizza.
You know,
I could have a sausage and mushroom
pizza at one of a handful of places in
new haven,
Connecticut,
and be just as happy as a clam.
No Pun intended.
I don't think it's your job to look
smart when you go to a restaurant.
I think you should be with the person
you're with.
If you're a solo diner,
that's also good than be with yourself.
Enjoy the place.
But I think a restaurant that forces you
to look a certain way or act a certain
way for their benefit is automatically
making a mistake because they're not
letting you be you and they're not.
They're not on your side really.
So actually one of the first things that
I would cage when I go to any restaurant
is to.
I feel at home here because there's no
law that says I have to go to this
restaurant.
There's no law that says I have to spend
my hard earned money at this restaurant.
If,
if I've heard great things about a
restaurant from a friend,
that's helpful because if it's a friend
than they presumably know me and they're
going to know that this kind of place is
gonna make me feel good or not.
But my rule number one is you're there
for yourself.
You're not there for me.
When you go to a restaurant,
I don't really pay too much attention to
the notion of what knight I'm ordering.
Something I would make one distinction
if New York City or anywhere has been in
the midst of a two or three week
heatwave in the middle of summer,
probably not a great time to get
oysters,
which just,
not that they're going to be bad for you
necessarily,
but they just won't taste good and at
the end of the day you're buying,
when you go out to a restaurant,
you're buying an opportunity to take
time off to restore yourself.
That's what the word restaurant comes
from,
but you're also buying pleasure.
You shouldn't be buying pleasure.
Um,
I think that good restaurants
today should totally be able to keep
fresh fish fresh in their refrigeration
system regardless of whether the
delivery came in today or yesterday or
the day before.
And the fact of the matter is very few
pieces of fish that any of us eat.
We're swimming yesterday anyway.
We would all like to believe that,
but a lot of the big fishing boats that
go out sometimes are out for a week
before the fish comes back.
I think that,
like anything else in life,
every coin has two sides to it.
And I,
I think that the good thing about more
and more food on television is that
we're now in a country where
good ingredients and,
and good cooking and good recipes are
not a foreign concept to people.
People are much,
much more aware of the role that food
can play at the table.
And I think that young people watch the
food network.
Last time I checked it's rated g,
most of the stories have a happy ending
and you know,
I,
I think that that the to the degree that
Julia child was able to make an impact
on a whole generation of people when she
was the only game in town,
I think the food network is,
believe it or not,
having an even bigger impact on even
more people.
And so I think that from a standpoint of
being a restaurant tour,
it's a good thing because more and more
people are interested in and follow
what's happening in the food scene.
The other side of the coin is that
the restaurant business is not a sitcom
and it's not
a reality TV show.
It's,
it's a real dated day,
persistent journey about delivering
pleasure for other people and it's a
very,
very humble pursuit and I think that
the,
the part of the,
of the TV aspect of food that,
that may be less helpful is that what
plays well on TV is sometimes brashness
as opposed to humility.
Serving other people is a humble act.
It's the belief that if I do something
for you
that's gonna make me feel better.
Sometimes that's not what's portrayed on
TV.
It's cursing and tattoos and brashness,
which is fine,
but that's not really what the pleasure
of the table is all about.
No,
I,
I think we'll see some changes and I
think we always have.
One of the things that's amazing about
my industry is that there's,
there's just this incredible,
um,
sense that there's always going to be a
tomorrow and you know,
I've,
I've now been in business long enough to
have seen for pretty serious recessions,
unfortunately so far to have survived
them all.
But it's,
it's like a mean,
nasty wind that blows a heck of a lot of
the leaves off the trees.
What I find amazing about my colleagues,
there's this never say die
entrepreneurial spirit and behind every
leaf that falls off,
there's a new bud that,
that,
that you know,
blooms and blossoms.
What's fascinating is to see what each
recession generates in terms of the next
generation of,
of restaurants.
You know,
I'll never forget all the way back in
1991,
1992 when there was a recession
connected with the Gulf War.
Everybody was saying back then,
this is the end of fine dining,
which was totally not true.
There was a period during which people
were eating more casually,
but we have long since passed the point
as a country where people are not going
to go backwards in terms of the quality
of what they eat.
No one's going to say,
oh,
it's a recession now.
I want to eat food that doesn't taste
good.
What they might say is,
okay,
I don't want to spend as much money or I
don't have as much time,
or I don't want to pay extra for all the
trappings of cushy chairs and beautiful
art on the walls and that type of thing
does come and go,
um,
the,
the restaurant that will be opening this
fall,
which will be called Maialino,
um,
based on my love for Rome is without
question a recession baby,
it's going to be a restaurant that,
that I would hope that people could
frequent even in a recession that won't
put it out of business,
you know,
during a good economy.
But what's,
what I also find fascinating blue smoke,
which is our barbecue restaurant that
has thrived throughout this whole
recession,
was born just a handful of months after
nine slash 11.
And it was born in a recession.
Two thousand and two.
And sometimes the restaurants that the
buds to blossoms that,
that come to life during a recession or
some of the most long lived.
As a result of that,
you know,
a Trattoria in Rome.
There are thousands of them and nobody
goes there to find cutting edge.
Nobody goes there only for special
occasions.
What distinguishes one Trattoria from
the next is the one that you go to the
most frequently.
So there are restaurants that are
created really for the purpose of
allowing people to be with people and to
break bread without a lot of the
trappings,
without paying extra money for the fancy
plates and the expensive furnishings in
the restaurant.
And it's really more about the soul of,
of eating well than it is of the refined
restaurant experience.
I don't believe that the refined
restaurant experience
ever thrives as much in a deep
recession.
But I also believe that there's always
going to be a place,
um,
you know,
for a restaurant that is,
that just gives you that extra sense
that you took a trip somewhere.
We have a restaurant,
11 Madison Park that just got four stars
from the New York Times and by all,
by all rights,
it should not be doing well in a
recession and it's doing better now than
ever.
I think that the things that keep me up
at night are the responsibility that I
feel towards the people who signed up to
work with me.
You know,
as as we grow as an organization,
it's.
It's really growing.
How many human beings are producing our
restaurants.
It's if you go to union square cafe or
Tabula or shake shack or the modern
tonight
and you have any comment experience,
I hope it'll be a great one,
but that experience will be a direct
result of the performance of the human
beings who work there and their
performance will be a direct result of
how happy they are working there and how
productive they feel and how jazzed they
feel in terms of the colleagues that
they work with.
How
you know,
how well we've helped them learn and
prepare for their job and when we let
our own employees down in any way,
shape or form.
That keeps me up at night because I know
that that's going to immediately
translate to our employees letting down.
Yeah.